I'm so sorry you're so close to my PC can you hear me I'm like really far away from the mic
can you hear me I might have to talk cause I'm so far away from you the mic
guess we got monetized it's your local funny
funny
the whole reason I got pedicure was for a monetization stream for ASMR via fate
thank you everyone who's applied to be a member my voice is a bit scuffed and wait let me see if I can catch up with a list
for some reason stream elements doesn't count in memberships and I don't know why hold on let's see if you're truthful let me read your news
I need a list I need a list but thank you everyone just this morning do it do it two tops oh yeah
this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this is crazy this
is crazy this is crazy this is crazy
I almost hit the maker of that
hold on
my ankle there we go
go to sleep
you've got monkey feet
I just have Krista here
ok
I've got face mark
I'm gonna see if YouTube will
tell me who my members are
so I'd shoot them out
right I can go back to the bottom I think okay this is the list that YouTube is giving
me don't remember me right now because I can't read it all out okay I've got pen
Kai, Theraminator, Zarian, Drop, Festasism, Outplayboy, Firefly, Simonija, Recon, Krustveder,
Harriet, Lolirica, Viral, Zahn, Bajinga, Sassafras, Namer-Law, Namer-Law, I can't do this all at once, I think I'm breaking your eardrums
and Harquins, Sky Noir, Zero, Elelelelelelelelelelelel, Kehre, Kazillionaire, Blackblood, Lundwar for real choke, No Alessandro, Vatma, Nugget, Bridge T-45, Base 64, Iron Reaper 1871,
Du Bois, Inner Witch, Glacono Samus, hold on like I'll actually do ASMR in a minute, hold on I need to read Imperial Monarch, San Brawley, King of Mufasa, hold on let me take some of those on my right leg
So the same words, P.O. Josephine, I.G. Mans, Mr. McSpliff, Destiny 2 Enjoyer, Cays, Seder, Abpron, The Manglecake, Larry, 28, Nova, Ma, Maher, E.O. Mahel
There's too much, there's too much, I can see all the new ones coming in and I'm trying to read the whole book
Simon, Toby 81, Otterbone Biscuit, Thumper Bucket, De Maia, De Maia Fork, Super Grump, Rilke Cadman, Asterix underscore, Pennant 1, Akito Henne no Quitchi, Jacob Otsikos
Yule, P.V. Mendez, stop giving me Mendez ships, I can't keep up
Hold on, I can't read them all, I don't know if this is terrible
Silas Nielilis, Firemaker, P.V. Mendez, Mika's Big Bang
Big is to read, you a nightingale, I turn a tiny spinny, I pour Kisua Raman, Kisua Raman, Sol Tinsert, Bero, I'm too old to read one, what name I'm too old to read one
Oh my god, I can't read, O B Odex, Plastic Ghost, I'm not gonna actually have to do ASMR between them
Oh my god, hold on
There's a few tools I got that are like require real ambidextory, but like
Crackpipes, couple of shit
Hold on, hold on, I can do this
I'm actually having a problem with this tool, by the way, I don't know what the lady did, but I think it's contracted and I might have to go with the doctor about it
Cause something's not right, um, I cleaned the wound today
And something's definitely not right, but I can't even get it to bloop
Oh wait, hold on
It's not blooping, I can't
It's a crazy amount of team effort to get this to bloop, hold on
Oh, come on, I'm just not turning over because of the way my feet are
Oh my god, I figured it out
Oh my, the little tool just cracked
Oh shit, I'm okay, I'm sorry, let me give my design a name
That took me so long, I also brought Pop Rocks to proof how sweaty my feet are, I want to see if my feet sweat can make them pop
Although just the feet sweat, nothing else
I just realized I'm really covering that up, so I'm gonna go over here
I don't know, look, it's my feet
Oh yeah, I also have a PC cleaner
These are used for fan board type things, but you need to like, squeeze them to get the air out
So yeah, I brought a lot of tools to try and get rid of my freaking feet
But I also got the frog thing, and it goes like
Like
Yeah, it's into the frog
Hey, I'm working that one, hold on
Okay, I'll try and say more names. I'm so sorry. I I'm very flustered when it comes to these kinds of streams
I feel a little pressured like
Oh yeah, listen to that frog. How are you so good with your feet? I don't know, how are you not so good with your feet?
I'm trying not to knock over the webcam
We'll do this, we'll try and say some names, okay
Uh, although next
Plastic Ghost, The Ruto, Cookie Fungbler, Kitsun Gamer, reluctantly saying Sakura and
Koku, Dinsu Dan, National Panda
Dragon Karma, Toasty Reef Oracle, The Coors
Um, Voltage Isaiah, Domino Miku
Okay, that was what was done offline. Now what was done right now
It's freaking impossible to keep up with but I'm gonna try my best, doesn't mean I can't try
Okay, I'm gonna try and keep up. Please bear with me. AC's in the room, bear with me. Okay
Could you wet? What?
Could you? Man, I wish I had little feet. Could you wet feet drying my?
Well, I bought pop rocks to see if I can actually get them to pop with my feet sweat alone, which is pretty gross
But I thought it was really funny. Um
Right, let me check where
The new names come in. I think
Uh
Zang, PV Mendes, Gaming Kitsune, Zorian, Outplayboy, Zero Bridge, wait a fire maker
Pio Giusefina, we have seen, I recognize some of these names, I've already said them. Um, Larry 20
Uh
Dejan Parma
Wait, I said these names. Oh, no, I don't know where his thoughts
Viral, San Brulee, I said that too
Draw
Everyone get in the name right twice or like, yeah, that's right. Forget you better forget my name. Yeah, I'm repeating sorry
I'm so hard. Right. I think we're here
Gizillionaire, I said Jacob Otscu
Um, uh, Sleepy Fennec, Eye Plorer, Super Grung
Not Alessandro Tenspenny, I don't know if I recognize them, I've already said these names
Oh my god George, it's so hard for me
Are you getting ASMR at least?
Congrats on monetization. Thank you so much. I'm so sorry. I'm like really out of my element with these kind of streams
I'm not used to like
I don't know. I'm just used to
Hopefully I can at least do some actual ASMR movement. I'm so sorry. I'm trying to catch up for a little
Uh, Takiwo
Karbunae
I had nothing
Scarecrow damn. Okay. I don't recognize saying these black wing 757
Why did that just change? Uh, Brian Yoko
I I'm a heron. I'm run
size
Oh, sorry, maybe your other ear should get something else
Um
Nak nak tuf 17 jack jackie a
Busbun yummy Ellie ball jackies
garaki and
Gentle near and scrumptious nightmare. We did it. We did it. I freaking caught up. I don't know how we did it
Thank you so much for everyone who is
Becoming a member and being so fantastic. I'm completely out of my element. I do apologize, but
Yeah, you like that
Was in your ear
But thank you so much for your support. You did it. Can you please scare him like that?
I was gonna do a fake cam on buckshot really
I don't know if I have to go to a doctor about my toe because something is wrong with it and I'm not
I don't know what on earth is going on
Oh, she did so on this toe
This bit here she cut into like really deep and I was like, oh no, it's fine
Like accidents happen. It was a little bit painful, but I didn't think anything of it
And then it's actually pretty sore today. So I don't know if I have to get it checked out
But yeah
The only good thing with your toe is it's not the only thing wrong with your toes. It's not my max. Oh my goodness. Okay
Oh
Scrumptious nightmare. Thank you for all this dino. Thank you
Grandpa thank you for coming to me
Yes, you're not supposed to cut it at all. A lot of shops do it anyway. Yeah
I think I may have got hurt a little bit, but it's okay. Uh, turi. Thank you
All right, well, let's see if we can open up pop rocks with their feet and get my feet sweat to activate the pop rocks
This might be very loud actually. Hold on. I'm gonna take it a little bit away from you. Okay
I don't know if I can do it with my feet to rip open
Anything is possible if you get your main stairs, right? So we have the
Gripper repair funds for 10. Thank you so much. Oh, wait, wasn't there a red? Why is it not displaying?
I could have sworn I saw a red earlier
I'm uh, it was a red
But jingle 100 in celebration your monetization. I gave you my first ever red so far. Thank you
Thank you so much
Do you guys think you better support the girls more than this? That's all I'm saying
Oh, I don't think I can rip it open
Actually having to use my brain power monkey feet go
I can't see if there's like a pre rip section
I can't see anything at all. That's why I've not turned my glasses. Uh, I'm trying to rip open, but it's gonna work
Support the girls
You've got my new ones
Congrats on the monetization. Thank you
It really wasn't that hard in the nicest
Streams as a screen brotherhood and nerds out about it. Oh, yeah. No, thank you. That was a yeah
I've worked really hard for that. Diddy. Thank you for becoming a member. Oh, I got a good call
Hopefully I didn't mess it up. Congrats, honey. Hi rain. I am so sorry rain. Please don't look
It's not what it looks like rain. It's a mistake. Okay
Hi rain
It reluctantly saying thank you for the 10. Did you want to put down a towel first last?
Nah, it's fine
the
The place I am renting the car kits weren't even cleaned before I moved in so
You get you get what you want back
Thank you, uh, I'll let
999 thank you for becoming a member. Okay, I don't know what I have to choose my hand
Sorry, let's hold on. Oh wait. I'll do it off camera. Watch this. Oh look at my toes go
Oh, oh, sorry. Oh, sorry. My toes weren't in frame. Oh dear. Oh, my toes weren't in frame. Oh, you couldn't see that
But I did get them open
So the way my feet sweat the most is in this section in between the toes. So this is what I'm basically going to aim for
This is disgusting if this actually pops. This is this is awful if this genuinely pops because of my feet sweat
This is terrible
Um, key if the spadey, thank you
If this pops, I'm actually gonna cry
Hopefully it doesn't work. I don't think I need
this one
Hold on. I need to sit on the floor for this
Oh, I need to do this with my foot
As if this pops
I can't hold them in my thorn
Did it pop? No, I don't think I did. I think we're safe
I think we're safe
I can't do it
Wait, did it pop? No. Oh
I hear it. Shut up
Did it pop? It's popping. No, that's so gross
I'm gonna step my feet this way. Hold on. Like
It popped. So now you're on the line about that. That's disgusting
But yeah, I got real sweat feet. I also have sweaty hands. Maybe I would do it in my hand
Oh, it's kind of the same thing where it's sweating between my fingers more
Salt feet. Well, you want to lick them?
Oh, right. Oh, no, it's getting sticky because my feet are over. I never thought this far ahead
Why am I so low IQ? It's such a curse sometimes. Hold on
Thank you Esteban Lomiel, if you're gonna remember. Thank you
Uh, Colin
Four, three, one, six, and thank you Shalom Plain
She kind of dumb though. Sticky feet mean sticky floors
Oof
Let me put socks on after this stream. Oh, there's like bits and spots everywhere now
You know what? Maybe that reefling was right and I should have put a towel down. Hold on. My sweaty hands are so sticky
They're like it's it's sticking to my hands
Look, it's actually a benefit
It's actually a benefit. Okay. You just have to think of the situation
Hold on. Let me just pop them up there. Our experiment has been conducted
Grows, I know
My ears have a pop rock sometimes. I'm trying to help. Actual squid behaviors
Honestly
Uh, this is welcome to the reefling membership tier and it says message redacted. I don't know how I was like, here you go
Thank you, Breyoko for the
Uh, super chat. Oh my god, super chat because I'm monetized
Found your credit card. Congrats. Uh, maybe don't
You don't have to support by the way. I always have free membership streams all the time
Today we learned to always put damage up right and we're going to actually do ASMR at the same time to hold up
Bull, I also got my skyrim achievements to work. I have like 12 skyrim achievements
I don't know why they weren't displaying but we might be able to actually go back to the skyrim stream at a later time
Boy, thank you for becoming the streamers. Totally bonkers. Congrats on the membership. Thank you
But thank you, boy, for being a member. Thank you
Uh, Sithman's for becoming a member as well
Yeah
Oh, you're getting tangled at the wazoo right now
Next week, yeah, um our endurance stream of the week is reefling
Hold on. Let me put these on, yeah
Thank you, uh
Shiori for becoming a member and thank you Dr. P for becoming a member. Hold on. This is going to take
some
manipulation because this ear
Isn't sitting the way ears actually sit
Oh
Um
You look on skyrim achievement and usually take like three streams unless your stream's super long. Yeah, I'm a bit of an endurance streamer
Okay
ASMR
Thank you, Jay for the membership. Thank you. Oh, woo wee for the membership
Oh no, they're coming off
Hey, just say
Wow those feet grew arms and hands out of nowhere. How a unique skill. Look, I'm a cephalopod. I have eight arms. Okay
How do you buy membership? Oh, you don't have to there should be a join button, but it doesn't work everywhere
So don't worry if you can't buy. I always have free streams coming out and the membership streams start
next week
not this week
Because by the end of this week, I'll have everything in place
Workwise so I only have to do shorts and I'm very glad
I am so glad that all the responsibility has taken off me
And I'm just a normal stromer
We should have changed all our names into
Jamal for the stream knowing
More hand you would have said every person
We should have one reflame
It's all arms anyway the logic checks that definitely isn't influenced by the
And the join button is sometimes not next to subscription on mobile
Yeah, I guess if you're in the phone, but don't worry. You don't have to directly support me
I'll always have free streams coming out like all the time. I'm not kidding. You can't
Take me off
Come on
You can't it's not possible
So don't try and take me off
Bless the shimmy. Thank you. We've got everything there. Remember
Are you doing
Me with my dogs are you doing hypnosis soon?
Not right now. No, no of these. I don't think I I don't think anyone can get hypnotized by freaking toes
You can see how opaque my skin is and you can see my blue veins
You check them things out. You can literally see them and my little tendons if you look hard enough for them. Yeah. Oh, there they are
Look at them tendons
Thank you for the tip. Oh, hold on string on the swing
Did brian talk right did brian say anything?
I hope not
Oh, it's kind of working
Okay
Stream elements is no kind of working mika's mika's big fan. Thank you for the five gifted memberships
Um, and then boys that trigger were just purple burglar alarm honestly
Brian said it but he was quiet good. I'm glad I didn't say it
Uh, bejinga. Oh and celebration. I get my first ever. Yes. I did
I'm so sorry. I'm very scared our brain right now
Um secret. Thank you for becoming a member. This is a crazy ASMR concept. It's maybe an ASMR. Let's be honest. I'm just home
I'm just home. See you and
I'm gonna feel
What
At their name
At their scrawny, I just want to
I just want to stream what I want and enjoy corpus. You can't do that
You'll never be successful scrawny who my beer makes whole companies of like-minded people to stream with
I cannot tell you how unbelievably
NICE is thank you for that a that type of there any I cannot tell you how unbelievably nice
It's to have like-minded individuals knowing these arrests
Like I jumped on my alternative twitter was like listening to the feed. I'm just sitting listening to ac
You know
Tinkle and I'm just like, yeah. Yeah, this is actually quite good quality. Honestly. I wouldn't mind if she brought a 3d one there
It is so nice to have like-minded individuals that are like, yeah, let's provide the goods
We say no to blue balling here. Okay. You ask and you receive. Okay. You ask other agencies. You get donor walled
Hold on. I'm gonna take a drink of water. I'm gonna put dehydrate. Please take a drink as well
So
Peeler allegations are yet to be resolved
I will make a public statement about the peeler allegations as you can see we're in very hot water about the peeler
What is donor walled donor walled is when someone
gives a streamer a lot of money via a donation and
the streamer doesn't read it out loud for
Whatever reason it may be they genuinely missed it. That's very plausible
Um, they don't want to acknowledge it because of maybe the contents
Um, but donor walling is the term when someone gives over money and
Thank you for coming on
Good luck with the pr camp
Okay, i'm me when jen2 comes out the p the pr camp
Peeler the best station in the world
Okay, I genuinely think I managed to catch up to everyone. Thank you so much for like all the love and support
I actually i'm like really overwhelmed right now and I feel so out of my element. I'm like, oh my god. What do I do?
Can I
I figured out
Right, so you may notice that my tier two is 4.99
I don't think it can be gifted unless on purpose, right? Like can you not just manually put in gift 1.99?
Internet bazzle
Feeze. Thank you for the member
Hold on. I'm like trying so hard to do this. Veeler needs to rehire a peer position a PR position
This is embarrassing I can't grip it. Oh, there we go. Wow surprise surprise if you used to the feet you can grip it really well
Hmm. Hmm. Uh, Jeremy. Thank you for coming to man bar. I'm so sorry to anyone. I'm alien right now in this room
I literally this is getting
Come on, please
Okay, here we go. We'll do it like this
What a strike. Thank you for the five gifted members. Did it do it more?
You guys have a look now
Jake Jake said pre lived grippers. Let's go honestly
Oh, there we go. We got it
Oh my god, we got it
The deck's theory
Just admit it
Just admit it. No other streamer is even capable of doing this physically because they wouldn't they wouldn't be able to do that
This is absolutely staggering. Did anyone tickle?
Or is everyone just like blown away by this and even being a stream concept?
Do you know how long I've planned this for? I've planned this for
I planned this
Back when I was concepted
To have french tits and nails, which is absolutely awful. I've been waiting months on this idea
To utilize it it manna's up one. Thank you for coming on this one
Oh, right. Can I do two at once? I think I can
Hold them by the bottom
Oh, we're losing them
My feet are so sweaty that they're right. They're up and then oh, they're up a bit too much
I can do this chat. Let me cook
Does that even work?
Oh my ankle just cracked. Did you hear that? Literally dual wielding the tingles right now
We're in on our we're in uncharted territory
Literally. Oh, for goodness sake. Why can I not do it with that one back? I wonder if the uh plaster is actually helping me grip this one
I'm dual wielding tingle. Oh, wait. I think my feet are actually getting too sweaty to pick this up because it's the wire
I
Think I'm literally right. Hold on. We'll just go the brush
Make me thank you for becoming a member. I appreciate you
If this isn't peak streaming, I don't know what honestly like with your
Would yours where the heck is my other oh here?
Dual wield brushes from one come on admit it. It's just so hard to do because of the ankle
Oh, there we go. I just need to relax the gripper
Is the Mars
I'm impressed
Did you watch the new ankle showcase apparently fable 4 is coming out?
We love joe feet wielding tingles. I bet you do
Wah, thank you for becoming a member. Yay fable
But they were saying and apparently the new dragon age origins has like a ton of little g fans really mad because there's something
The
Oh, and my feet are actually too to get into sway
Hold on
She's foot maxing on
No
From a 200 build in Skyrim to a dual wield built the next day so talented I knew I knew
Isn't this amazing because look at the gel shine on that big toe
Look at that shine. Oh, that's gorgeous
I
Do
Oh my ring late there that's which uh late enough the deck under here because it's all dark
So that's what the gel polish is doing
Uh delicious brown white food
Thank you for becoming
Not 3d what should have been me
Hammerfell is gonna come in 2026 if we're lucky. I'll be so interested to see if I'll enjoy the game or not
I might be one of those games where I have to play offline for the first time
to even appreciate it. I don't know if you ever like
You know your first playthrough of a game you're so silent and so quiet because you're just
Experiencing it for the first time. So I feel like it would be hard to commentate
Like I really want to play big ball these days, but I'm worried
I won't have a thought like a single thought formed because I've never played it before
I'm sad I can't hear but the visuals the visuals though. Yeah, you like the vision
Oh my god, can I do the middle finger on a tool?
And then bring you back up again
And then everyone go down. Oh, no, it's not gonna work. I don't have that kind of
I don't have that kind of tool dexter. You have the cane where I can like grip around and stuff
Yeah
my appendages
My appendages, I'm actually tempted to leave these on because it's helping to muffle me making any mistakes
Crone
shimmer pants
Thank you for the time. Congrats on monetization, Stony. Thank you. Thank you for the direct support
A fan made more remaster of oblivion made in Skyrim's engine is coming out into it with us here
We do a little tapping ASMR
It sounds like I don't have the dexterity to do the frog thing
If Walsham Gromit aren't becoming Crimes of Beyond on our film. Oh, there's a Walsham Gromit thing coming out
How far can your pinky go? What do you even thought? I'm gonna go like
Sky oblivion
Get Nordic get Nordic get Nordic
It's commonly referred to as sky oblivion by the project workers. I mean, wouldn't they not get a season's assist if they're doing that?
Cup your ears. I'm cupping your ears
There's also a mod project that makes all of
Nym
I would love us the moral wind remake would come out, but we were hope
Geez Gromit. I'm sure there's like a new Walsham Gromit thing coming out. I don't know if it's amusing
Because everyone was like, oh new Walsham Gromit before GTA 6
No, because it's fantastic fan made mod is free. Ah, so they got away with it
But then that doesn't actually get up a day about more than asset impact
Fallout 3 new Vegas thing. What were the accusations that Fallout 4 got the most useless update recently?
And it was to spite modders to break them all or something without Fallout 4 or did I make that up?
The amount of complete rework done in Skyrim engine is crazy
Oh
Daniel or my microphone, by the way, it keeps picking red
but
Yeah, they had more than you'll hope their studio got burned over stuff and all of that way from the Walsham Gromit
I'm playing Fallout 4 right now
They update Fallout 4 due to the show and it broke all the mods in the mod. Oh, okay, that makes more sense
That makes it good. Okay, it keeps picking red and I'm like, am I am I'm like rippers to okay for this microphone right now?
Hmm
Peter Salas, the voice gromit passed away. Oh, I guess I don't have to get excited
That sounds good, I'm glad
I'm sorry, my ears are fine. My ears are okay
Um, just so you know for the replays, this isn't an endurance stream. I'm
I'm very out of my element with the webcam on and I'm like
Okay, now what?
I'm like, okay, but thank you so so much to everyone who's membering thanks to so so much
everyone who's like super Chan or Tiffin or anything like it's such a fantastic help and
um like obviously I don't want to say too much but
You know, it takes a year to create a new generation. So this is very reassuring
Um, if there may or may not be some plans in the background. Ho ho ho
Um, we love mommy. Love you Eastling. Thank you. Seriously. Like I'm a bit overwhelmed
Like I literally have my hands like this because I'm like, oh, okay
Um, I was nervous because I don't know what to do. These are what's to say. Genius idea. Please. I was going to do a
webcam stream on buckshot relay and then you guys can tell me to put my feet back on the floor because I'll always sit on them
Absolutely there was a gorgeous laugh
Thanks
Yes, I just filled out my element. I'm like, I'm used to meman
I'm used to well, I guess this stream is a big mean to be honest. I don't use to put that much
like
What's the word that much? I did bring
I know everyone is tired of japanese youth cleaning tool and it gets done today
but
it's true
Thank you
Tico so well for becoming a member. I can't pick this up. Hold on. All right. Thank you, bernie. You said for becoming a member and thank you
el
ka
Wow
Sorry, I'm late. No need to be sorry at all. Thank you for becoming a member. Forgiveness sake
When it's really thin, it's so hard to grip
seriously
I feel like I read just like them right around to like bring it closer
And then I need to take this off gently. I can't even do that
That's right. You're cleaning via foot
Or whatever
I don't know internet basu file meal talk
It's cool to see you willing to be able to it's a challenge even with a handful of people much less
It's 300 this is 600 throwing money literally
I I'm definitely not a hand cam streamer. I don't think I don't don't expect any foot cam hand cam
After this, I'm gonna be honest. I'm like, oh, it's not for me, right? We're gonna do this as gently as possible. Okay
gentle
Thank you for coming to my ear cleaning foot spa experience
I ran to thank you for becoming a member
Now just let the brush
slowly glide
across your ear
And as the brush cleans the outer ear
Hold on you will find yourself. Hold on and I relax
There
Just like this
Instructional ASMR just let me ASMR you
Oh, yeah, that's right. That's the money shot
Oh
I'm trip my poor pinky. Look how hard my pinky is trying right now. My pinky is like going to france without hardest time
I'm trying to like use
You can't be feetlings anymore after the stream, I don't think you're feetlings
I think uh, I'll stick to the VTuber model because I'm like so nervous with the webcam on
Plastic girl, thank you for the 10
If you like feet though, Emmy's doing foot cam stream later this week. Okay. Emmy Beezoo. Her link is in the description
Subscribe and hit the bell if you are into
Because she's oh, I just dropped it. I didn't notice I dropped it. Hold on
Right and then I need to pass up to this one. This is my strong foot. Take my strong foot
Refling take my strong foot
Refling no don't fall grab on to my foot grab on to my french pedicure foot
French manicure pedicure
Thank you. Rune desolation to welcome the member. Thank you jargon hearts for becoming a member
This is literally my left foot is like unless
Unless I hold it like a pencil
Hold on I need to like dab against myself
Just know whenever you hear ear cleaning in my ASMR role plays. It's not done by my hands. It's done by my foot
I spit holding him
Thank you everyone for membership and supporting me. I appreciate it. We are testing if tier two needs to be higher than
um
4.99 US dollars, but I don't think it has to be not from what I've seen
Oh, no, it's dropped again. Jeez
This is really difficult. I thought I had a bit more. I think because it's so thin
Okay
It's gone again. I'm going to have to joe wield this
Double the twos
Uh
Be
G. Thank you for the membership. I appreciate it. We're swapping. We're swapping. I can't do this anymore
I said let's do the bubbles
I
The most bizarre monetization celebration I've ever seen. I've actually outdone myself. I've actually surprised myself
Weird this concept is can the bubble come?
Sorry, that was probably really loud. I'm so sorry
I hope no one's actually consuming this stream
Uh, uh, uh the level of like loud ASMR. No, don't listen to the stream at ASMR levels
Don't be silly my skull. We're fine. Okay, I was gonna say don't be silly and listen at ASMR levels
My feet are literally the pilot. You're telling me you trust my feet not to ever make a blip
I know my ear drum's still there. Ow my ear. Yeah. No, don't listen at ASMR levels. Don't be silly so much
There's absolutely no way right
So
For some reason stream elements can see when you guys gift other people but it won't register a membership if you bought it yourself
I don't know why
You're kicking in domestic
Fiat, thank you for becoming a member. Is your name fiat for a particular reason
I don't know
What that's strange. Yeah, I don't know why
No, I'm gonna lie to you your voice overpowers any sound I could have paired so far would mean the difference
Hi, Stony, congrats on unlock monetization. Thank you
Oh
Thank you
Remember just for anyone listening. You don't actually have the member by the way. I always have free content coming out
So, please don't worry
Please make sure you look after yourself first such as you pay off your debts because we live in a society
And if you're debt-free, it's good for you but bad for society
But we can get into that in another stream
John
John zero seven. Thank you for the membership. I appreciate it. Sorry about all the camera glitching by the way. This is a very
Dusty
webcam a very dusty
Narrow, thank you for becoming a member or narrow to two seven six
Like I was supposed to say your phone. I might want to do it because the cameras think okay
Peppermint did I say that right pepper peppermint
There's no arm
Okay
You never mind. Okay, never mind. Oh, we got there in the end
Don't worry, Stony, even if we get our ears bumped, you're still the best put stream
Oh, is that my new title now? Like the best
I would honestly take that title. I'm quite happy with that title
Oh
It's all right
My feet are here to comfort me
When it has been a long day. My sweaty grippers are here to
Pretend to tangle you because let's be honest. This isn't an ASMR stream. No one believes at all
This is an ASMR stream just because you have the three view. It doesn't make it an ASMR stream
Which is why the title is called monetization celebration stream and not ASMR
Uh, watch mercy stream. I was wondering if you can do a Q&A too. I would absolutely love to you. That is I would love to do a Q&A
Maybe we can read membership membership marshmallow. We can read marshmallow. Absolutely
Air Rock Starly
Yes
We can 100% do
Marshmallow reading that would be fantastic
um, although mercy was like purposely like
Seeing stuff wrong, which was quite funny like really giving bad advice
Logan have a let. Thank you so much
If you hear my stomach, it's not because I'm hungry and starving
It's because I got our massive loaf of bread and Nina wouldn't come out before the stream
I went to the toilet three times and I never came out. I'm sorry for your stomach
This could be really funny for an April full stream. Well, you and the grippers out again
What would the title of the stream be?
Too many people ask real questions, but most of my scenes of the vice was real was it? Wait, hold on. Let me get my marshmallow
It's like as a movement
Uh-oh
And then I'll I'll go up the link. It's only a couple, okay
You ask me anything and before I can hardly say anything that is
Wait, where can I find this?
I would like to pin it but the love heart is in the way
I don't someone at youtube you're telling me not one person at youtube
Is aware of this issue and fuse
April fools. How does it April fools if I've already done it? I've already got you the gag is been done
Okay, that's my marshmallow thing
And
Oh
No, tier two is what's getting gifted mommy you have to raise a pegs for both ears
Wait, no, I only want emotes to be gifted. I wanted to leave emotes as $199 and I have to make it $5 for tier two
Honestly the mental
The mental stress of raising it by two cents is really good to me. Hey, babe badding gadding. Thank you for the membership. I appreciate it
We did warn you. I was just wanting them to work so badly
Oh, I don't want to raise the price. I have to apparently if I want to raise the price
I need to close the tier and then open up a new one. I don't even know what happens
It only lets you donate the 499 tier. Oh
I'm so happy to have you back. I missed you. I missed you too. Oh, that's so annoying
and
Oh
I have to raise the price by freaking dollar. So by dollar by a cent. So if I make it
You would leave emotes at $199 but tier two has to go up to $5.99
Oh
Does it actually have to be
Yeah, you has to go $5.99
It's just a dollar do it, but you don't understand
You don't understand the principle about how much I can glow and brag
That's only $9.99 to support your oshi for a month. I feel or you don't understand
Okay, but it's kind of more of the youtube channel having to make problems. It's fine. Oh
So right I guess after the stream
For those of you who sign up now for the tier two
I think you only have to pay the one dollar difference to get on the tier that is
Oh, that's so annoying. Can I can I make that new tier live at least or is this like
I don't know how youtube's gonna take this
Oh, I don't know youtube's gonna like me hold on
Levels edit levels
No
It locked in the price is locked in I don't want to put up a dollar, but I have to
Oh my god, please youtube sound right. I have to basically add a new let tier
Oh for goodness sake wifling member stream tier
Oh and
Oh for goodness sake
You know tier
Oh, okay. All right. Hold on. We're trying to do it together
Right. We need to do it in american double laws united states set a price
$5.99
Let's give that man a backshot. What wait, what did this happen?
We're doing it live. We're doing it live. We are wifling
Real I'll just put wifling member real tier because that's I'm out of things and then add a pair
Fucking
Membership stream membership only live streams
This the real deal
Y'all
And then pair of instructions nothing because you guys don't need to do anything the next what happens
I understand that once my offer is reviews improved. I'm unable to change to introduce a new price
I can create a new level and or delete any existing deleting a level will cancel existing memberships if that happens
Okay submit for review. Yes my tier my mem my freaking
membership streams do not have
Sorry, I'm like straight up talking. There's a thing
No, it does not come right. Your perk is being sent for review. It said
$5.99
Well, that's so expensive. I'm gonna have to stream like way more than
I'm gonna have to stream more to earn that because 5.9 is really getting expensive
There's even display the damn thing
Uh, right it doesn't display it because it's not been approved by youtube question mark
It's one dollar
So like all the tier 2s will be reset
So the tier 2s can upgrade via a dollar. I'm like 90% sure you already stream more than most. It's no problem
We can buy one less candy per month. You already stream every day. Yeah
Well, you're ready for multiple streams in one day of different things. Yeah
Am I losing my membership tier?
Maybe
Why does it not work? Why does it not work?
So what does this say is it there? No, it's not been approved. So you can't see it
Ellie bot. Thank you for the membership upgrade. Why does it specify you upgraded? That's so specific
Oh, no more streams. Oh, no. Thank you for fixing it
Yes, so we need to wait for youtube to approve the new tier and then that's the actual tier
Um, I guess but I don't know how long it takes to get it approved
I wonder actually I wonder if youtube is going to be able to see that is so similar to the second one
And they're going to be like, yeah, you're dumb. You praised it wrong. Didn't you and I'm like, yes, I praised it wrong
Please forgive me. I'm sorry
And then youtube will be like I will have mercy on yourself
Your levels are approved publish. Wait, what I already got approved wait
Hello youtube. Are you watching me right now? I promise I'm not doing anything bad
Feet are a natural part of the body. Um, thank you for monetizing me youtube
Please don't take it away. Is youtube actually here right now? Why did it just get approved?
Is it approved? Is it live? Wait, hold on. Let me try
Oh, okay. Wow it is. Okay, right. I'm going to delete the other tier
Okay, thank you for upgrading. Did I delete it now? And then oh my god, everyone's upgraded. Thank you so much
I'm so sorry be funds. I'm so so sorry. I've completely missed this
I've absolutely balls this one up. Right. I will delete the
How do I delete it? I do I will delete it delete this level if you delete a level
Members of that level will lose their membership
Consider notifying them before deleting encouraging them to change levels any member that purchased this level this month will be
Reimbursed. Okay, that's good. Any member that purchased this level this month will be reimbursed
Okay, youtube. I'm reading that myself. Once you submit your changes, they'll get approved. Delete
Next
Submit and review
I understand that once my offer is reviewed and approved all members of deleted levels will lose their membership
It will be reimbursed for the last month. Okay
Submit for review
We're doing it live. Okay, we can do it live
Do it live
publish
Did that work? What does it say now?
Wait, hold on. Let me refresh. Hold on. I think we did it
Hold on pause. I think we did it
We did it. Okay. I will not mess up with the girls
But I will okay there we go
I believe it's fully working now if you do gift memberships
It will only go to refling emotes which I need to add a sugar ton to
Because it was like you're only allowed to add four emotes until you get more members
So I'll add to the rest and I'll commission a ton more because with the amount of membership
I think there's quite more than 10 slots that I have. Thank you so much for your patience for me doing this
Thank you everyone who is I upgrading to the new tier
I do apologize
and
For the mistake. I really severely wanted membership gifting to be on emotes only
Because I didn't want to charge more than five
99 no
4.99
But thank you everyone. That's upgrading. Can I see your upgrades? Nope. Uh streaml is just really doesn't like it
Um, that's very curious
Uh very curious indeed
But I won't mess up for the girls when I enable it. I don't know if and when I don't know shebe's doing hers right now
If she is it's a surprise. I don't know if I'm the only one who's currently doing the membership member
Oh my god, I don't think wait, it's not telling me the upgrades
No
It's not telling me when you've upgraded
It's
Like on my screen on any screen. I'm so sorry. I don't think I can keep up with the upgrades. Thank you everyone who's upgrading. I appreciate it
I'm so sorry. I suck. I'm suck as a streamer
My apologies for such a
Unprofessional start, but then again, is it really me if it's not unprofessional? It's so over
We will support the cut for this regard. Thank you
I think it's not an upgrade now because it's the tears gone. So it's just a new membership. It's not register
Oh, is it register?
Oh no, this can't be wait, how am I supposed to?
Oh, wow, so it's not even telling me if it's an upgrade now
Okay, this is good membership not showing in your stream elements as a bug with your stream elements account
I've contacted their support of
Okay, I wonder if because stream elements is for twitch really
Um, but thank you so much everyone for upgrading or becoming a member of the tier. I actually
Can't remember if I've said around them
I thought we can just send it you're more professional than many streamers you treat us like humans
Who streams it doesn't treat you like a human?
What?
Please tell me there's not actually streamers like that. I remember
When uh, you guys taught me that people get actually jealous like if they see you in someone else's chat and I'm like
Huh?
That's real because I thought you guys were memeing on me like teaching me this and I'm like wait
Some some vtubers expect you to solely watch them and only then
Um, the it was very eye-opening very
Boy, thank you for the tip alert this
Yeah, for some reason I can see that on stream elements, but nothing else
I can see if someone gifts membership on stream elements as well, but that's it
Some people are a bit cray-cray about it. Hmm. I see be sweating right now
That was that was slightly different. I understand where she said that. Yeah, it's a lot more common than you think
I'm only gonna have time for you to try
My 12 hour streams. Yeah
Oh
Thank you for the gifted membership
Uh, I poor thank you
You oh you need to allow gifts. There may be a prompt in chat right now to allow gifts
Uh, make sure you click it. I think you it will say that you can receive gifts
I don't know how it works
My membership just got refunded. Did I miss something? Yes, I had to change the price because gifted membership
um
is
Was the wrong price. So thank you everyone who's resubbing. I believe you got a refund question mark question mark
Which is really good
Yeah, we all got refunded that was really quick. Honestly shout out to youtube if everyone literally got refunded that was so quick
Where is the join button on mobile? Get right. You're on mobile. There is no join button
It's just a mystery the join button's more of a suggestion than actual rules
And thank you everyone for resubbing. I'm so sorry, uh
D. W. Thank you for subbing giving kids any con
Sula's
loli wika
Asterix I'm like pretty sure I've said all these names before. I'm so sorry to anyone whose name I haven't said before
The join button is on the youtube page
Oh, if you want my youtube page, apparently
You guys have such funny gamer tags, honestly
Sorry, I meant 21 so for 21 days not all at once was in a rush to a brain loss for about to clarify
Okay, I was gonna say that was quite the length
Being inspired by the 21 days of brushing mean the micro plastics will be purged. Oh, that's okay. I like that
I subscribed on desktop with PayPal on the old 499. So what now
You should youtube should have already refunded you apparently apparently everyone already got refunded like within seconds
um
So the new tier is one dollar more due to the fact that gifted membership
Will go to emote tier which was what I wanted, but I was so stubborn and like oh, yeah youtube
I'm sure youtube will make sure that you can't deny
Streams at that price, but no no youtube insistent youtube insistent
Uh a PayPal alerted me about spending it should
Vtuber foot connoisseur. Thank you
What a name what a name to show up in this stream with
What a name. Thank you for becoming a member that's hilarious. Mika's biggest fan. I'm thinking
Art form biscuit. Thank you
What a name honestly, you like the french tip as a standard for you
That's right. Where other vtubers don't provide I come swipping in on week one
Week one. I give you what you seek
He really is a connoisseur. How's the winded toe doing?
I'm I had to take painkillers because it's getting a bit sore
I may or may not be making a doctor's appointment
About my toe because something
I'm going to see what happens. I'm going to go for a bath after the stream and let it sweat it out like in the hot water
in vultkine
black blood
Through
I still forgot this is week one. I mean technical. Well, we're just entered week two I guess but
If youtube stats updated immediately, we would have been monetized day one
But it took a whole week for it to thinking this is week two my apology fee. Yes fee
I'm so sorry if you don't like immersion breaking although I am literally as white as my
I'm actually I'm so white. I'm transparent. What the heck did I just move there?
Well, I think like you can literally see my veins and like the blue if you didn't know
Veins are blue and they carry deoxygenated blood back to your heart
They also have blip back
blow valves which are really good that stops the blood from
Going backwards in your system because if your blood ever goes backwards, that's very very very bad
And yeah, you're probably not going to make it if your blood starts going back
Strongest parallelism and we're like, yes, and then your arteries are what the little red veins are hold the redness
That's pushing oxygenated blood to
Where it's needed and then your circulatory system takes care of the rest. It's really quick. That's me
I could also talk about the heart if you like today. Thank you for signing up
Oh, you've got a banding of Isaac. That's uh, uh, what what's that x?
Uh, the fucking loser one
That's a
sass and fries
That's swine up. You guys really poke them on in video game
Uh pictures as quick as well. Thank you for signing out. Your feet are beautiful. Don't worry things. Yeah, you like you like seeing the
deoxygenated blood pumping through these veins
Um
I can't wait for you to play binding of Isaac November. I'm just warning you all right now
November is when binding of Isaac's 10 year anniversary is and molly player is unlocked
I am not going to be off that from you can see my hands in the shadow. I am I am instructing you
I am not going to be off that game for a very long time. Okay
Do you understand we play?
And then you all say I understand mummy and unison, okay?
We're going to be playing multiplayer Isaac all day long multiple days
I might even I might even commit to a week and alienate more people
with my binding of Isaac
Just so you understand better. Thank you for signing off. Thank you. I understand. I understand mommy. I understand mommy
I understand. Yes. Good grieflings. Good grieflings. You will be rewarded for your
Uh, oh wait, so I didn't really so much my shadow was like cast you over you will be rewarded
Wait, if you can see my shadow, no, we'll do that in a membership. So
That was a very bad idea. That was a terrible idea
Little ears, please let me pick up this this q-tip or this ear cleaner as we say
Let me just pick up this ear cleaner
Just need to hold it like a bit
Put it there we go, right you ready for some ear cleaning
Oh, poor you see if you get trapped water in your ear, don't worry too much your ear can expel it at a later time
and
Some people actually find that expelling of the water in your ear quite. Oh wait, you can't even see me touch the
This is right. I'm going to do a basic
I'm going to show you a basic 101 for any ASMR is that's watching right now. Okay
And I know this is very hypocritical because I've just bashed the ear about
I'm going to teach you this right now live. Okay
You see this ear
Inside this ear this black section
This is what you don't do. Okay. This is what you don't do
You
No, no ASMR is you go around the microphone
Around gently, okay
Don't don't ever don't ever touch this bit here
That's the microphone. Okay, but go around the ear
Gentle
Gentle gentle gentle gentle
Okay, there 101 is more
This I'm gonna try and avoid doing with the tool
I just around the ear you don't need to go inside. No, no, no, no, I know I know you guys like to rush into it
Okay, why are you covered in band-aids? I caught myself making food
I hurt myself on my fingy
I'm glad to put a band-aid on
I'm I'm a bit of which is known as a klutz
Uh, thank you. I had nothing
Dried my karma the terminator above of the great
Does that mean you were making food with your foot? No this
I got all my toes done at the same time
But this part so when you get your toes done they take clippers and they they take this like push thing
They like pushed all my like
Toe skin back and stuff
But this section on this toe she has cut that was actually kind of sore touching that I'm not even gonna lie
She cut and sliced into it as she was cutting my toenail
Um, and it's quite sore and I'm not really sure what to do
and
I've not really experienced such a problem before
But we will we'll we say I think we'll be okay
Thank you star killer for becoming a
Do you use a new fluffy instead?
Wait a minute, I got a thicken tiny
It seems like you forgot for the next one in from yesterday spain II lol
Spain II that's what I said. Anyway, I'm off to work Celia and congrats on monetization. Thank you for the tip and yes
Thank you spain II
You could literally hear me like be scared to say it because I say it wrong all the time
Strani, do you have a stethoscope?
No, I don't
That would be quite the prop for a smart honestly having a stethoscope
Uh, you push back the cuticle of the nail bed cleaner, but the actual tool lining is not a cuticle
You should probably get it to like muckers
This is great, but I have class now. Okay, would you like class get educated get educated get educated get through well
Epsom salt foot bath
Yeah, I think I might do something like that because it's a weirdo
I heard someone say use it for heart beat ASMR. Oh
Would that even work? I don't know if we tried
I wouldn't mind buying that prop. I will buy that prop with my membership money. Thank you
I hope we're through here. Yeah, I think we'll be fine, right? Sorry. Let me look at the Q questions on marshmallow
Uh, congrats on the membership. You're the goodest girl around. What is your favorite meal to eat savory something savory?
Hello, will patreon subs get to see the membership streams on patreon?
Nope, they are two different subscriptions patreon and youtube activity are two separate things
So if you're interested in seeing your
Your girl and your oh she deaths live then that is more youtube orientated
If you're interested in the alternative content that any member at valer offers, that is what is on patreon
Thank you for your question
You have big feet for a woman. Okay
I don't know what you want me to do with that. You might sign up for basketball
Right. Sorry. Let me just end the stream. I'm going to contact nba
Big feet. You think I have big feet. Are you sure it's not perspective because you have nothing else to judge?
Literally what big feet is good. Your feet are great. Literally everyone's been saying my feet are cute and stuff
And then you come here. You're like, yeah, your feet are massive. I'm sorry
Do you want me to bind them like we're in fucking china or something like back when they used to bind the lowest feet?
Is that we want you want a little fucking lowest feet? Get out of here with that shit
I don't know anything about food, but they're normal me. Yeah
Like oh, sorry, excuse me
Oh, I see when I spawned in uh when I spawned in I actually picked this foot size manually
You know, there's a little slider bar and everything banana for scale. I don't even have bananas
Oh, do you want this do you want my stoop waffle that I ate yesterday for scale?
There there's your scale
Your fear
I've no sense of permanent. So I'm just going to assume you're a talking therapy. Honestly
Who said that who I don't know what feet size are you I actually don't know
um
I've not bought a boat. When did I buy a new pair of shoes? I've completely forgot
I had to get measured for them actually when I got a new pair of shoes because I didn't know what my shoe size is
Uh, I don't know what to say here to be honest, but I'm glad for she be uh, don't remember
She's really cute and the gap was really nice. Sorry strongy and uh, the year long wait was worth it. Oh, I'm glad you think so
Some people were asking like weren't you worried about like everyone being disappointed after a year's wait and I'm like
I'm sorry, but if you're if you're a leaflin, you knew what you knew we were mean
You knew I was rambling. You knew exactly what was going on
Merci, when are you doing about your membership stream for no particular reason?
uh
Star killer. Thank you. Uh, new yudi julie. Thank you
Uh
Swirly lexa six
You have thank you for signing up your profile picture around to me
I could have bought a freaking hip no thing and put it on the floor and hypnotize people to my feet
I'm doing so funny though
We're squishing the ball we're going back to squishing the ball. It's so easy to squish a ball
Feet cam feet stream q&a. Will you ever beat the peeler allegations?
I don't think so
I was gonna um
So when the girl started posting it for free
I was like, oh, I was gonna do a donut on reward where I wrap my 3d open
like a poly bag
like a plastic bag
and
Hypnotizing the reefing to your feet to convince them I worship the feet honestly
Goes in a strong a stream your feet are big good for gathering produce all day giley
Literally, I was like, I've never seen you in my life
And now you want to do it for free? Yeah
I was gonna make it a fun donut on work because I was gonna do it on 3d. Oh mate
But I need to wrap it up to make sure it doesn't you know short circuit
um
Was this a bit being in a bag might need that stream
Hey on reefing on what pee pee's on you
You still can
3d moment as terrible honestly. Oh my like donut on plans are absolutely outrageous
So I was like, hi, love you. That's all
Really
So says pokemon or digimon. Sorry. I only saw pokemon
I never got into digimon because wasn't it wasn't the digimon meme that's literally like
Oh
This like cute adorable thing ends up developing like an ak-47
And like a galeel on one arm a famous on the other
The only big thing strenny has is her
Her her heart she has a really big heart
Hearing your feet sweat stick to the ball reminds me of ear coughing when the hand leaves the ear
Stop wait, I think my feet are sweaty enough to do
What does this sound like?
Oh, that's great. Oh, you actually like it. Thank you destiny to enjoy, okay
It sounds nice
Can I do to it? Can I do both? Hold on. I think I can do joe wield ear cupping
Oh, sorry, I just peaked the audio
It's a bit more difficult this way
It sounds good. Wait, there really are sticking to the ear
Did you miss the pop rock segment where I proved how sweaty my feet are via pop rocking?
I just realized the maker swap is it? Oh, no
Is it on the wrong side I can swap it out manually if you want
Peaking the audio just means you're peeking
You want to hear my heartbeat from my foot? I don't know if I can do that
I don't think you can hear it
I go here 10 minutes ago. Yeah, the start of the stream
um
I may or may not have opened up pop rocks and put them on the soles of my feet to prove how sweaty my feet are
And they popped
No outside influence necessary. So I have proven that I do have hypo hydrolysis
Not that anyone needed proof. I don't know why you would make up such an accusation in all honesty. I would anyone want it
Thank you
Glaesos
Yeah
So fancy
I get sweaty feet too. Yeah, uh, just just as a mild warning to anyone who's listening if you have permanent sweaty hands and feet
Uh, please do consider uh autism. Um, that's all that's my note
Oh, can we do toe tapping ASMR?
Oh, yes
Uh, yes, it's actually a very common satree um of having autism uh by having permanently sweaty hands and feet
What if you have hairy palms? I don't actually know
Maybe you're Italian because aren't Italians hairy?
I am acoustic
Oh, that explains a lot actually. Yeah
Yeah, we have strong arism though
Little toe tapping ASMR, that's right. That's right average vtuber recharged thousands for this in a donut stall on me
You get it for free
I never noticed it until you actually mentioned it, but yeah, I do have autism and sweaty hands and feet
Yeah, it's a very common trait. Um another sub if you are
um
Depending on the scale, however you want to scale you can do it different ways
But if you are on kind of like the high needs side of autism
Um, if you do toe walking only that is a massive indicator a humongous indicator
That you are kind of on the upper uh scale of the prison needs. Thank you
gin
Isuru channel
And thank you
So cracks
Uh
I used to have I have to use antiperspirant on my feet anytime I had otherwise it's blister sitting
Huh, I never noticed that before but you're right about the sweaty feet. Yeah
The toe walking is too real toe walking is a humongous indicator that um
The child that normally it's noticed in childhood
Um, you can unlearn it as you get older, but it's a massive indicator
I used to walk all the time. Yes. It is one of the biggest giveaways if a
Child is autistic basically if they toe walking
Got used to some powers for goods
Literally well like without mine like I had um
Um
It was stroking my ego. They're like, I don't know how you do it. I don't know how you like stream
I'm like
Do I tell them the truth and the reason I can stream all the time is because I have autism
Or am I just like oh, I'm just really passionate. I just really like what I get to do like
For me, it's always sitting in weird ways that put so much pressure on my feet that I keep getting callous
Yeah
I told run is that similar told running maybe isn't the biggest indicator
And in children, but then like you can start like it's
She's unstoppable
And I walked on toes as a child and then my feet are
Don't don't be shy. You can finish the rest of your sentence
We don't bite here. We don't bite from around these books
I got
This is enough to what else can I do I freaking I've brought this stick in some people like wouldn't stick a somewhere
I've never particularly found it easy to record it. So the only thing I can do really is just tapping
like on the ear
Oh
Any other major indications of autism? There's tons like
Stimming with hands lack of eye contact is a big one
and
My biggest question to you if you're like sitting here and you're like hold on a minute. She's starting to she's spitting the truth
My biggest question if you genuinely are like, huh is
How different would the world look if
If everyone thought like you how different would the world look if everyone thought like you and before you're like
That's not an indication. Just think about it a bit more. Okay, just think a wee bit deeper into that question
Okay
Anyway gifts are messed up everyone's getting tier two one dollar
For something we really wanted so why
One more dollar for something we really wanted so why
Why was that because
Oh wait, is this an old sorry, this may be an old message
Sorry, I'm reading
I'm so happy to have you back. I miss you so much. I miss you too a lot recently
Okay. Yeah, sorry. Those were old ones talking about the tier. Thank you for anyone's info about the teams
Uh
World ends up addicted to watching veal
That's how we take over you guys thought my hypnosis was to drown you all. No, it was to
Oh my god, my feet are so tall
I'll put your mops on to protect you because
I can get a bit from it
Uh
Right, let's see where we are
What strongy you're the strongest at least mentally
I don't know about physically me who struggled to open a can of fizzy juice on the hand cam stream
Can I buy or use band-aids to put on an alt or um
This one literally has gunk on it. I don't I don't know what's going on this tool, but we'll figure we'll figure it out
Uh girl I've ever known
But someone like you should never mess with infections get that tool checked ASAP. Oh monk. Yes, okay
If you had to take painkillers, you can go the ER, but I know you'll never do it because you're a sweetheart
but somebody else could
Sue that pedicure. Oh no, she didn't mean it
You should at least show them the medical papers you get from the hospital monk. Yes. Am I going to the hospital because I'm a toad
I'll tell you what I'll update you some twitter after my bath
I'll do a soul plingy and see what happens because so so normally
and it makes out
Would you be playing and would you be interested in playing omega strikers on stream? It's a 3v3
mob style air hockey that's free to play. Oh my god. That sounds fun
Omega strikers
Oh
Thank you. Whoa, and thank you panel
Titian
Oh, no, the mega strikers look so cool
All their waifus are cute
Isn't this free to play? Oh, no, it's nintendo
Oh, no
It's nintendo
Nintendo so expensive
Is it nintendo?
Oh, yeah, oh, no, this can't be this can't be it can't be nintendo. What is this a nintendo noton now?
Uh, it's on pc. Okay. It's on pc. Right. Oh, okay. Okay. It's fine. It's fine
It's fine if it's on pc. It can't be overcharged that much if anything is specifically published by nintendo
Just know you're gonna get rinsed out ours for the price. It's absolutely ridiculous. Whoa
Wait, I can see that it showed up pan up to shion pan option. Thank you so much for oh my goodness all those gifted memberships
Whoa, wait a minute stream elements is assigning your gifts in real time. I can see who's been gifted your gifts
Oh, thank you so much
Congrats everyone who managed to catch that you do have to enable it in chat
Um, i'm so sorry. I can hardly say the name pan optician. Surely it's pan optician pan optician
Thank you so much for the 20 gifted. Thank you and congrats everyone who called up their face
It's all coming together
Yes, you'll have to like I think you have to talk in chat
Even if you just say a simple message like hi, and then it'll be like you could have got this enable it
I love you. Will you go on a date with me? You better come to the convention. I'm giving everyone roses
I think if we ever did like an actual convention
I'd love to buy like single roses so I can give it out and I'd be like, ha, that's right
You have beat all the odds of a man never receiving a flower before he
All right, hold on. Let me hydrate let me hydrate
What convention where no, there's been no picked convention
But I really want to try it once in my life. I've never been to a convention before
I've never been to like a location that has been self identified for nerds
um
And dorks like us
So it would be a very unique experience. Wow. That's like literally real-time assigning
Um gifted memberships. That's crazy
That's so cool. Um
Vial or conno
Well, the only thing is I have absolutely crippling traveling anxiety, which is a bit of a problem
There's a big convention in california. I think
And a lot of the girls would actually be able to make it manually. I think if we all went but
I don't want to let the team down
There's a lot of issues about getting on a plane
Um, and I get violently motion sick as well. This is why I just want to farm with
You refling because I can't travel anywhere. I get so sick like I had to get a taxi
I think a taxi to my dentist appointment and I it's not even that far away from me. I was violently ill. I was like
Oh
I was like, can I just put the window down and the guy's like, yeah, yeah
He's like on his phone talking to his pal and all that. I'm getting scared
Oh
I'm gonna use thank you narrow for becoming a member. I can see that
Get drunk and pass out on the plane. Honestly
I got I will be so high on medication. See the problem is I don't want to be like
I'm definitely going to a convention
Because I have a bomb and a bomb really messes up things that happen in real life
And I don't want to be like, oh, you should go to this convention in melbourne for this on this day at this time
I'll be here because I don't want anyone to spend money to come out on the the sole reason to come
Like see me type thing
Because if my freaking a bomb gets in the way
I
Oh, wait, I'll tell it. I'll tell it in another stream. Okay, but I have a really freaking
It's really frustrating, but it's quite humorous at the same time
But yeah, you could be the one of those robots that meet up. Yeah, that's possible first mercy next round
Do other girls have motion sickness?
Oh, no, I can still play video games. I have like travel motion sickness
Like a parent. Oh, wait. No, she put those goofy goggles on her eyes. I'm pretty sure she did
No, you're right about mercy. She put those funny goggles on her eyes
What is a bomb a bomb stands for anxiety because people are sick of hearing about it
Like the word anxiety. So I just call it a bomb as a substitute
um
It's ear problems
Oh, well, I can fix your ear problems with my sweaty feet. Oh, yes
Oh, yes, you can handle that. Can't you? So a little tool rubbing ASMR?
Yeah
That's right
Maybe don't say that in airport. Oh, no. Yeah, we we're not going to use that terminology
I think stronti can fix their ear problems on her page
I mean your motion sickness. Sorry
Do you take game suggestions? I absolutely do. I have absolutely no issues. Um
A lot of streamers kind of don't
No, that's not nice. I will not generalize. Please. Don't be afraid to gap her bucket. Thank you for becoming a member
and please don't be afraid to you don't ask me questions or
Um game suggestions are perfectly fine with me. I have no problems
and
It's that how many people use a bomb as a word for being male to interpret. Yes, like I
I kind of generally touch up on the subject
Just because like I am very thankful to be where I am
versus where I was
And but I feel like people are so tired and burned out hearing about it and like, oh, everyone's got it
And I'm like, yeah, I need wonder everyone's got it. Have you seen
Have you seen society today? We live in a society. No wonder everyone's gone up. Anyway, we can do that
I can talk about that in another stream. This stream is supposed to be me celebrating monetization
And yet again, I'm talking about the how that we need the downfall of society. It's terrible
It's shocking
And we got his dempa in here. No way dempa is in here staring at my toes right now. Oh god. She is
Hi dempa. I have no idea what size my feet are
I bought like new shoes last year and they had to measure them and I already forgot
My shoes aren't in this room
Sorry dempa. I had to be this way. I literally am
Yeah, dempa, you should do foot cam ASMR with me. You want to you want to come over?
I feel like you would have smaller toes than me. I've never had a pedicure before
Oh, well, if you ever get one, just make sure they don't mess up your toe by the way because mine's an agony. So
Yeah, you definitely need to be careful with that
Here's my beefling heart
The world is uh, there's no surprise
I have a broken pinky though. Oh, no. Can you know like spread your little look at my pinky do this little dance?
Oh
I don't want someone to touch my feet. I get a massage is very unique sensation
um
Very very unique sensation dempa x20 for you ASMR
Poor dempa's pinky thing
Are there any game genres you want to avoid? Um, I don't like oh, this is going to be controversial
I might filter some people with this one. Um, the reason
I do not like games like resident evil where you give me ammunition, but it does not perish the enemy
Do not give me enemies that cannot be perished. What is the point in having an ammunition resource management section?
If it does not perish the big bad enemy, please do not suggest these kinds of games
It will turn into a rage stream real quick and I will become so scots
You will not actually be able to understand me. I'm sorry, but do not give me ammunition if it does not perish the enemy
Simple as I mean that's fair preach
Did you put hydrogen peroxide on it? No, I'm going to take a bath. I'm going to take this off and go for a bath
and
Do salt in the bath
You mean you like that 30 bullets to kill that one enemy? Yeah
Yeah
I'm sure the resident evil games are good. However, I have fantastic news
I have five gen mates that are more than likely to play that kind of genre
I've never played resident evil my I watched my dad play resident evil
And it started off in Africa, but he couldn't even get through it and we were both watching it and we were like
Well, I was watching him play it and both of us were looking at each other like what is this?
Like he couldn't get through it. I couldn't get through it
um
Oh res fat. Yeah, I was like set in Africa or something like I it was like super hot savannah type thing
And both of us were just staring at each other like this is the biggest piece that we've ever bought
um
Because normally we like play games together or share games together type thing
You watch your dad play the second worst one. Oh, well, there you go
Literally, we I think we've got 20 minutes into it. Both of us were looking at each other like yeah, that's that game's going back
We're gonna hand it in for a different game
Is there something you've always wanted to try that you've made for 100 games that gave to you?
I've want to play
Civ 6
um
I have done one run on it and I enjoyed it but I was very dumb and I want to play boulder's game
I definitely want to try that for the first time
But I think it will be a patience testing stream because I get worried about playing a game for the first time
um
5 and 6 are some of the best sold ones regardless
Wow, I think for free. I yeah, congrats on monetization
Uh, let's just make sure
Right, I think
um
As soon as I think your feet are very beautiful. I'm hot. Thanks. Do you have my toes? I got my toes down
Look at that stepping
Look at that side profile on the toe spread. Can I just get a zoom in an appreciation for the side profile of toe spread? Yeah
I mean look at that. You you already know you're welcome. Yeah, you're welcome. You owe me one membership. You're welcome
Um
The new boulders gate. Yeah, I've never played the boulders gate. Apparently. Yeah, someone says it's cool. But primary's cool
That's delicious. You played any rts
Uh starcraft. No, my dad played it
age of empires
Civ 6 is a dumpster fire
Is that actually
Didn't they not ren- announcers a new Civ 6?
Yeah, a new Civ coming out
Long toes wait, they actually have long toes stop. Do I have long toes?
There you go. I'm gonna start again. Hold on. I'm gonna get that really right. Hold on
that
I don't know. I feel like I have like the toe because you can have like people some people have like toes that oh wait
Sorry, you can't see any of them. Hold on. Let's try this again
Some people have toes where they like are all the same length like they come across like that
minor like
the
That shape I don't know if that makes any sense
You feel cute like your toes are cute. I'm gonna start getting a complex about my freaking toes. Are you joking?
Right, how long are my toes right? We'll do it in inches because you're all american. You said 2.5 inches is
Wait, hold on. I'm like trying to show you and do it at the same time
Where is 2.5?
Uh
Where I am my my index toe is just bigger than an inch
Sorry, I just hit the mic. Oh, you're not american. I'm sorry. Um, um, um, hold on. Uh, okay, roughly
3 centimeters tall
About 3 centimeters tall
I am fended long toe equals more than joy. What the fuck is an inch?
Three of these baby
Measure the entire foot. Oh, no, but then you will know I've got big feet
I did oh no my foot's bigger than the ruler. Like if the ruler goes there, it's like
If this ruler's 15 centimeters
Wait, hold on. Let me put it as a thing
Okay, I put it on my heel and it's there on my toe. So I'm like 16 centimeter feet
Yeah, sorry, that was like the most known way to do it
But I did it
Big feet are good
But you have no big feet the mic is low
I don't know. I might have I
I genuinely thought I was like average on everything. Um, but then when I did the
Sweet eating cam and everyone saw my hands. You're like, oh, your hands are so small
But when we started measuring it together, I was like, oh, okay
Imagine if this is popped right now because I'm a sweetie
Can you measure how wide you can spread your
Big toe and the one next to it. We have weight
Uh, I don't know like because you could like this is that we want to hold on
Thank you so very sweetie
Like that or do you mean like the actual foot? I don't know it depends. That has to be malleable
Uh, this is gross measurement
It has to be malleable like it has to be like because I can grip stuff like
I'm gonna just grab my hold on now. Can I move you a little bit? There you go. There you go. Just pop you there and good boy
head pass
Uh this
It depends because like that is you know
And I can put it in between like
I
In the culture she would have nice grippers
Down her renders and chat. I guess your feet are small, but it makes your toes really long and compact
No, I'm gonna get a freaking complex after this dream. I don't know. I just thought my feet were really normal
Oh my cat's me on did you hear him?
Do you want in
Did you hear that? Hold on
Hold on let me get him
Baby boy
You want in
Vigo
Vigo you can't even just oh
Gimli Gimli do you want to do you want to come on stream?
She's so confused right now. She's like, what are you doing?
Gimli come here
Gimli come come right here. Come right here. Show the people how adorable you are. No, that's the wrong way
Gimli what's this
Gimmels
Yes, yes, okay. Just gently don't knock over the webcam. I'll cry Gimli don't knock over it right out
You're gonna knock the webcam over Gimli
I've only got 10 more minutes. I'll be out in a minute Gimli
I didn't get it though
Give me 10 minutes Gimli just 10 minutes is all in me. Sorry. My tube is sweet to hear that
Mommy Gimli that was a
She was so gonna knock over that way of cramps. I was like get out of Gimli. I could tell oh
Oh, I've done it now haven't I?
Gimli 10 minutes and I'm
Stop it
Your dog is very cute. Thank you
I'm terrified for eight years. You're for your perfect. Thank you
Literally, I shouldn't have brought her in because now she's gonna want the attention and I was like, I'm not finished. I'm not finished
Give me 10 minutes girls
10 minutes of getting screamed up by a cat. Literally a cat does not understand
Feet time
She doesn't have a cat. She has 10 doves
Yeah, that was my Gimli. I thought it was my baby boy Vigil
um
Thank you very much
Voltaums and thank you for ronald. I appreciate the gifts and memberships. I could
um
Cats and feets. Yes. I picked up. Thank you. Caleb Harris as well
um, I
adopted Vigil and Gimli and their starting situation is actually really sad, but it's a really happy ending so I
I messaged a shelter and I was like, hey
um
I work from home
I would love to open up my home to two cats that cannot be separated if you didn't know
For adoption agencies and all that kind of thing. It's really hard to re-home
doubles
That are inseparable
Um, so I messaged them and they came back and they were like we have these two
Ruffians
And they have come from an hoarder's home. Um, which makes them un
They cannot be with any other animal but each other. Um
So I went and visited them and they were these poor scaredy cats. They genuinely were so terrified of any humans. Um
Thank you, yummy for the memba
Thank you everyone who's like remembering as well for the correct tier. I do apologize about messing up that tier
Um, yes, they're a bonded pair and they can't be separated
But I just want to say the universe works in mysterious ways. Sorry. I know I'm supposed to be doing ASMR
I'm just trying to call them right now without the microphone for
The world will work in mysterious ways now
I do not believe in supporting certain cat breeds which are bad for their health
An example of that is the munchkin breed
Vigo is mixed tabby and munchkin breed
The universe will find ways to laugh in your face
Because I am a big believer in like completely no longer breeding them and not letting them be a genetic line any further because it's so bad for their health
San Baroli, thank you very much. And then the universe laughed in my face and said guess what?
Your baby boy is a hafu and I'm like, okay
Motons, thank you for the upgrade
So yeah, if you ever think the universe doesn't have a little joke for you
Oh, I assure you the universe is gonna it's got a joke for you
Yeah, like pugs. Yeah, I am a bit of a
Please don't support but this was just me. Um, like scotch fold cats. Um, that was adorable as they look
Absolutely not. Hairless cats. Absolutely not. A lot of people will say like but I can look after them
It's not about you looking after them. It's about the general population looking after them
Does the general population gonna do all these steps about looking after their cat and the hairless ones
Gaining at a bath and removing the dirt cells because it's not got freaking fur. No, it's not. Thank you the bigger picture
Anyway, um, don't get me started on um
Animal breeding because a lot of it is just absolutely insane
I'm waiting till you get started and learn about what pedigree dogs are. Pedigree dogs are just certified. Um
You literally get a certificate saying yes, this dog has been produced via freaking insane amounts of um
Cest and it was like why is pedigree even a thing? Get a mutt. Muts are the healthiest kind of dog you can even get
Like ah a mixed breed cats. They're the healthiest kind you can get like don't support the little munchkins that have freaking stilts for legs
It's actually so freaking sad and I can't eat. Oh, oh, I could really start
Anyway, uh, yeah, the universe will always have a joke for you
So, yeah, uh, I despise munchkins
I don't for the for the kindness of the poor cat
They shouldn't be a thing and then the universe said oh, by the way, Vigo is a half mix of tabby and munchkin
And yeah, he has saucer eyeballs. I should actually post a picture of my babies. Um
But yeah, Vigo has saucer eyeballs. He's so adorable
and the universe won
Hey, do you do rabble and durian streams where you just go down a bunch of rabbit holes? Oh, absolutely
Um, I did it in my sky room one. I started talking about the navy streamer overload ending where she becomes a god
And starts a new religion type thing or like starts a new society
Um, and like I started talking about conspiracy theories and stuff
But I don't like going too deep into it because I know it like really just like people didn't like it
So I was like, okay, I will maybe it too much. So it's me
Hey, my mom used to read lavenders but regarding cats makes heads. Yeah
Vivo is just a small rock every scrawny rage makes me a lover even more all Vigo. Yeah Vigo my cats in Vigo after
The the guy did did you know in door to the rings and the scene where he kicks the helmet he was screaming for real
Do you want to know why he screamed out for real like that?
Because because he actually booked his to and yeah, and yes
Did you name your cats after the lord of the rings? Of course I named my cats after the lord of the rings
What else would I name them freaking bill and ben the flower pot man? No, I wouldn't
So yeah, my baby boy my baby girl and yes, I gave
Gimli
Well, yeah, I gave Gimli a boy's name technically
But Gimli's got ginger on her butt. So
Gimli ma homina
Yeah, name them bill and ben the flower pot man, honestly
Oh
Holy crap, you just made me remember bill and ben
JJ you've got a picture of me
Thank you for the membership JJ. I appreciate it
Just for all members who are watching the membership stream start next week, but I promise you I will throw you into the thick of it
Um, and we'll have a lot of fun from there
We'll take it from there
Because this week is kind of locked in a little bit. We do have a collab again with me and all my girly
You are an adorable goober. We love it
Uh, yes
What's next Roseanne Jim?
Yeah, I'm not gonna get any more uh putters
after Viggo and
Gimli I think um, I will probably have the biggest uh
mental breakdown of my life
Once they pass thankfully I have them very young they I think they're three years old
Unfortunately due to the hoarder situation, they actually don't know what age my baby boy and baby girl are
Like I was trying to get as much information that they had but they were just very honest and said like look we don't
We don't actually have information on these babies
Stroney, do you know if you get a cut of youtube premium membership watches? I absolutely do
Um, if you pay for youtube or it used to be called youtube red, but if you do youtube premium
um
For however long you watch it like I get a percentage. So say you 100 watched me
I get 100 of what you generate for
Content creators does that make sense? It's the only percentage base to the best they can
I've noticed my favorite troopers dabble in theories must be one of those jokes from the universe
Honestly, the universe will have a little funny joke for you. Like please if you're ever like
Thinking oh, there's nothing interesting's gonna happen in my life
I assure you the universe is cooking something because I
I am the biggest like don't support like pugs don't support
French bulldogs like don't support munchkin cats don't do this or that
And then the universe goes oh, by the way, here's a half munchkin. I'm like, oh, okay. I see how it is. I see how it is
This is shooting is kind of hypnotic. Yeah, you can like see the balls move around in it
It's just quite nice. I quite like it
Wow
It's like really therapeutic to like squish down into it honestly
I'm not being like I'm I genuinely wholeheartedly mean it like it feels very nice to like squish something under my feet
Go to go have fun with the rest of the stream. Congrats on monetization. Thank you
Yes, please don't worry if you need go and I am going to redirect into the sheebie
Actually, is she be up right now? Hold on. I'm I'm leaning over
She's live right now with another crabs treasure. Oh, yeah
Apparently the music in that game is like so good, but it's a dark souls crab
I thought it was like a fun little crab game
I was gonna play until someone said it was like it's like dark souls and I'm like, bro
If I can't if I can't tag in the refluence to help me that's a game. There's a point
Um, I will most likely do a talking stream membership one for next week just because there's so many
Marshmallows, I can't really say but we can say
Yeah, I hope you enjoyed this fake ASMR roleplay
Roleplay aside from roleplay literally wasn't even ASMR. I'm talking to you at normal levels that I normally do for streams. So
There's all
It's us souls crab game, honestly adjusted the years boy. Thanks for the stream sonny. It's what sonny
Thank you. No, alessandro for the two. I appreciate it. I really hope I've managed to say everyone's names
Thank you so much for your patience as well as I completely messed that stream up and wholeheartedly
Just like yapping in tone. That's all we're doing here
Best stream I had feet and a kitty. What more could I ask for? Yeah, that was gimme
Love this. Thank you so much. Thank you so much. Yes, I will go now
but thank you so much to everyone who members shipped and
Gifted and don't know and etc. The membership streams start next week because this week's schedule had already kind of been logged in
And I didn't actually know when I was going to do the monetization
Thank you. Doofus
Doofadoff
for the member and again, if you can't membership, please do not worry
I always have free streams coming. I always have free content coming out. You just need to give me a little patience
Um, but the dust is definitely starting to settle from debut
Which means I can like fully focus on like everything I want to do
Lex, thank you for the five gifts. I appreciate it. Congrats on those who caught it with your face
Um, no the music. Thank you very much. I was very kind of you. Um,
But yes, the dust is starting to settle
Which is good
Because I mean I can start focusing on the free content I want to do and all the stuff I want to
But yes, please say hi to she be for me
I'll type a few messages in our chat and then I am going to go soak this little toe and see what happens because
Yeah, my pro toe isn't doing so good
But we'll see we'll see
Okay, right. Bye. Bye for now. We flings. I I would I would like do my little kissy, but but this is the microphone
Can I kiss you with my toe?
Right this this is my kisses
Hmm
Bye-bye replays. Bye-bye. Look, I'm waving you goodbye. Bye-bye. Oh, this is like really hard
I'm like doing on an axis here. Bye-bye
Actually, I can shake this foot really fast. Bye-bye
Okay, bye-bye. I'm gonna say hi to she be okay. Bye